david of the various films that you've
made I'm wondering how you come up with
the titles we haven't really asked
filmmakers on how they come up with
titles and you have some very
interesting titles mm to your films so
what is it that strikes you about a
certain set of words that you think
would grab people um oh it's a good
question you know it's I think it's been
different every time in jiro Dreams of
Sushi how did that title come about i
mean we actually i had a number of
different titles we knew we wanted to he
always talks about how he dreams about
sushi and so you know I wanted the title
to come from something that he said and
in this case we were kind of playing
with the phrasing of it because you know
he says that every night I dream about
sushi so we were just kind of playing
cuz it's in a different language we're
kind of playing with the syntax of that
and jiro Dreams of Sushi just kind of
came out and one of our friends um was
like oh it sounds kind of like a
miyazaki movie you know like one of the
you know Hayao Miyazaki mates these
incredible like Howl's Moving Castle or
spirited away is really interesting
title so we thought like jiro Dreams of
Sushi kind of sounds like an adventure
of some kind or something evocative so
it just kind of felt right in the case
of a faster horse that actually idea I
believe it came from our producers
suggested it and as you know i wasn't
sure maybe somebody will say something
that's right but throughout the course
of making the film we realize that a
faster horse was kind of perfect and the
title of faster horse comes from this
very famous quote by Henry Ford where he
is what he had me Ford was asked in an
interview well how do you know what
people want I mean do you ask the
farmers what they want you know how do
you decide what they want and Henry for
he goes you know well if I ask the
farmers what they wanted they would just
say a faster horse they don't know what
they want it's my job to kind of predict
the future and create something that
they will want they just don't know
about it yet and I thought you know
that's really interesting because of
this film is about innovation it's about
Lee Iacocca kind of creating a car that
would be accessible that would be
beautiful yet affordable to the baby
boomers who didn't know that a car like
this could even exist and be affordable
it kind of fits and you know made me
think about you know Steve Jobs and you
know how he created you know nobody knew
what an iphone nobody could ask for an
iphone you know they had to see it and
then understand how to like it so I love
the idea of these kind of visionary
people who can predict what somebody is
going to want without needing to do
market research and stuff like that and
the Mustang is a car that was not did
not have market research it was a car
that they they went with their gut and
they put out this car that was beautiful
and affordable in 1964 and it just blew
everyone's minds and fifty years later
people are still enjoying it right as
you show in the film and we'll talk
about more of that in a second I was
curious for a faster horse did you have
a hundred percent of the production
budget in place or did you get it sort
of piecemeal as you began gathering the
interview no the it's an it's an
interesting story about how this film is
makes I don't know that it's ever been
done like this before where basically
what happened was you know the Ford
wanted a 50th anniversary car sorry 50th
anniversary film for the Mustang to tell
the story the history of the Mustang and
to capture kind of the global phenomenon
that the car has become so they allow
Lucy Ellie who's this producer who's a
he's a they think he's the great
grandson of Henry Ford the second he has
connections you know with Ford he works
with team detroit their advertising
agency and they came to our producers
and said we want to make this film about
the Mustang but we want it to be a real
movie and you can do anything you want
with it as long as it captures like the
main kind of feeling of Mustang you can
do anything you want they came to me
they told me that I could do that and I
felt like wow that's kind of amazing to
be able to have unfettered access to
look behind the curtain at a major
corporation making their most important
product and they'll pay for it but I can
do whatever I want in the making of the
film you know with the guidance of my
producers because you know no film is
made by one person but the fact that
we'd really be able to make a real movie
out of it was very attractive to me so
the film was fully financed by Ford but
they were not they did really didn't
give us any notes they really didn't all
that they did was open the doors for us
and let us
and I think that we had a lot of
goodwill because of jiro Dreams of Sushi
they loved that movie they saw how it
kind of put emotional context to sushi
and kind of change the way that people
look at sushi in the craft of it so they
were hoping that I would do the same
thing for the Mustang fascinating well I
know that you had one interview that
really stuck out to me and that was a
gentleman forgive me his name is
escaping me but he said that there are
days that you go home and you think wow
no one wants me to be successful and I
was shocked that he was so honest about
that especially within the corporate
realm oh yeah yeah yeah because everyone
talks about the world did were a family
were a team and we don't let each other
down and and I thought that there was a
lot of truth anybody who's ever had a
corporate job can probably attest to
that on Sundays taking that same mindset
do you feel in making a film maybe not
so much this one but in in of the others
that you've made were there days that
you ever went home and thought gosh I
don't know if people really want me to
be successful sure um well yeah I mean I
first off for the the people that we
interviewed for it are fairly fearless
in the way that they're able to just be
completely honest and that's actually
one of the reasons that they're caught
you know they've been doing very well
and their cars are very affordable but
they're good and I think that one of the
reasons for that is that they have this
kind of corporate culture where people
are allowed to take risks they're
allowed to make mistakes without fear of
reprisal and so because of that they're
really able to reach and like do what
they feel is right and so that kind of
like honesty within the companies like
really impressive to me that that was
how tight aying who said that yes
sometimes when you're the chief engineer
uska home and you're alexic everything's
going wrong nobody wants me to be
successful and it's more of a feeling
than a truth you know I think that you
know as a director things go wrong and
you're like it's easy to take it
personally and you know you can
sometimes I get that feeling where it's
like oh like you know there's something
wrong with the online or like the color
correction doesn't look right and
nobody's paying to fix it and why are
they just trying to screw me over and so
that's a feeling that you get because
you care so much about what it is you're
making the pressure of being a chief
engineer of a car is intense I mean it's
a billion dollar in
investment it's um and it's all on your
shoulders you know the success of the
car is writing on you and your taste and
your vision and your ability to
communicate your taste and to motivate
this massive team of people to to
execute it so I mean it's an incredibly
high pressure situation and it's hard
not to take it personally and one of the
reasons if you're able to make a good
product it's because you take it
personally and because you care so much
about it so you can certainly you
certainly there times when you certainly
get emotional and I think it's really
awesome that you know they were willing
to share that with us and we were really
able to watch them go through the
process of building this car works and
all through the highs and the lows and
there are lows in the film and things
definitely go wrong and which makes the
success all that more satisfying so I'm
really kind of lucky that they were
willing to just share it all with us and
just briefly touching on the same idea
but taking it in terms of do you feel
that way sometimes in building a film
career not just a film but a film career
right do you still have that same thing
where you think maybe it's just on the
person taking it person yeah I mean I
think I don't think that anybody I've
never felt that anybody has not wanted
me to succeed I feel like I'm very lucky
that I have my producers and my crew and
everybody that I've always worked with
I've been very fortunate to have a group
that I work with repeatedly a lot and we
all are striving to make something cool
we all want to make something that we
want to watch ourselves and you know
because we love to watch movies just as
much as we like to make them and so we
want to make things that we all want to
watch and so it's important not to take
it personally if something goes wrong
something isn't exactly the way you want
it to be you just have to find the
solution and we work together to find
the solutions but I never take it for I
never feel like somebody is trying to
screw me over or anything like that good
good yeah there was one gentleman in the
film that said that he sometimes can't
sleep at night and he said that when
they were building the new Mustang
people just like don't screw this one up
oh yeah is this one just oh sure yeah
and it actually could be and that's
because you know it's very different if
you're building a new car that's a new
model that nobody had heard of before um
it's a lot less pressure than taking on
an established
r and that is like a legend in the minds
of people it would be similar for your
FileMaker to making a new Star Wars
movie I mean JJ Abrams is I'm sure that
his BS had moved because of like the
mail and all the crazy like letters from
people telling exactly what the movie
should be and you know everybody has an
opinion on it so that just raises the
stakes even higher I got a slight taste
of it making this film because everybody
had an opinion of what the mustang
documentary should be like and what are
the right Mustang models that should be
included in the film whenever we would
interview Mustang fans they'd be like
okay make sure you get the fox body
models in there you know they're like
looking at like I got my eyes on you and
it's really interesting because you know
it's in this myself too much smaller
extent but dave has the hopes and de
perro sac was the chief engineer of the
car the main character the film the
hopes and dreams of the Mustang faithful
are kind of like on his shoulders and he
has to make a car that they're going to
love or you know it's going to be it'll
just be a big personal disappointment
for everybody so it's a very high stakes
thing to work on something that is an
established brand that people care
deeply about that being said was there
anything in making this movie that you
now looking back on it wish you had done
differently because you did make it not
just about the car but also very
personal journey of the people involved
you leave your one gentleman's house Tom
and spoke to his family and I was
surprised that you had such access to
some of these people that didn't want to
just be seen as he's like corporate they
were human but anything that personally
you felt you wish going back you could
have changed or not I mean there's so
many things there's so many things I'm
very proud of this film I'm very proud
of all of our team members who worked
really hard on it and they're all their
work individually i think is spectacular
on the film and it forms a greater whole
but of course watching the movie there
are so many things that i would change
and that's true everything I've ever
done even going back and looking at your
dreams of sushi everything I've always
done I've always felt like there is
something more that we could do um but
uh that's okay and that's always gonna
happen you know I'm not gonna tell you
what those things are okay I tell you
what the stakes are but um you know
there's always a way to do better at
something I really learned from George
reams of sushi working with gyro know
who he's in that film he's 87
years old he's the world's greatest
sushi chef three Michelin stars and he
still looks at a sushi is like you know
I'm just kind of starting to get the
hang of it and so I think that's kind of
like a perfectionist mentality and so if
you're ever satisfied you're like oh I
did the best that I could and this is
the best product that it could ever be
then you know maybe that's the end of
that's that's the end then you know I
always feel like there's a there's
always another level to strive for and
so but you also have to be okay with
your product and get it out there you
know so I think that you know we do the
best that we can with the resources
available and we make something that we
enjoy watching and when i'm at the point
of watching the film where I don't feel
like I'm not cringing I don't feel like
ashamed of it then we're in pretty good
shape but there are always things
usually it happens maybe two months
after the movie is picture locked and
it's impossible to change things you get
the new great idea but you know what you
just save that for a future movie
basically yeah